Hit and miss transform
Another variation on mathematical morphology
is what's called the hit-or-miss transform.
Now in this case, the structuring element
contains pixels which have three possible
values. The value could be zero, which means
that the pixel that it sits over must be zero.
It could be one, which means the pixel that
it sits over must be equal to one or it can
have a value of don't care, so it doesn't
matter what pixel value is underneath.
Let's illustrate this with some simple examples.
Here are two input pixel patterns, and we're
going to overlay this particular hit-and-miss
transform on top of each of them. Now in the
first case, we see that the result is true.
The red pixels in the structuring element
lay over zero pixels in the import image and
blue pixels in the structuring element lay
over input pixels which are all equal to one.
So the result is true. We don't care about
the other two pixels here, what values they
have, they do not participate.
Now let's have a look at this example.
The red pixels in the structuring element
lay over pixels, which in this case are not
all equal to zero. The blue pixels in the
structuring element lay over input pixels
which are all one, so that's good. But in
this case, the result is false because of
this one valued input pixel over here.
The hit-and-miss transform can be used for
a lot of really useful and interesting applications.
Consider this input image here, it's a synthetic
image that I created using a bitmap editor,
but we could think of it perhaps as an aerial
photograph of a road network or something
like that. Now, by applying a particular sequence
of hit-and-miss transforms over and over again,
it's possible to perform an operation called
skeletonization. And what we've done is to
convert our input image which contains a number
of lines of arbitrary thickness into a skeleton
of that image.
Contains a number of lines and each line is
guaranteed to be only one pixel wide. Now
we can perform this skeletonization operation
using the toolbox function called ithin and
you pass into it a binary image. Now this
operation is quite slow because this hit-and-miss
transform is relatively expensive to compute
in its own right and to do skeletonization
we have to apply the hit-and-miss transform
over and over again to the image in order
to obtain the skeleton.
Another really interesting application of
the hit-and-miss transform is to find intersections.
So let's assume that we have the skeletonized
figure created in the previous slide and I
want to find the intersection points. An intersection
point I'm going to define as a place where
three line segments come together at a single
point.
And in this case, there are five intersection
points. So I want to find the pixel coordinates
where these three single pixel wide lines
meet. I want to find these intersections and
again we can perform this function using the
hit-and-miss transform. In the right hand
image we see the five intersection points
highlighted and each of these is just a single
pixel.
The pixel is set at the coordinate where those
three line segments meet and we can compute
this intersection using the toolbox function
itriplepoint. The input is a binary image
that contains a single pixel wide skeleton
type image.
Once again, this triple point function is
quite slow to execute because the hit-and-miss
transforms have to be executed iteratively
until there are only these few isolated pixels
remaining.
Here's the synthetic image that I introduced
to you earlier, it's loaded into the workspace.
It’s a six hundred by eight hundred logical
image so the values are either zero or one,
so I can create a thinned version of this
image using the toolbox function ithin, I
parse in the logical image and it will compute
for quite a while, almost a minute, and here
it is.
If I display this in a new window. Display
the thinned image, we can zoom in on this
image to show that it is indeed a single pixel
wide. Zoom in again and we can see that it
is just a single pixel wide line. A whole
bunch of white blocks stacked end to end.
Alright, unzoom that one.
Now I can compute the triple points and I
do that using itriplepoint function from the
toolbox and this function and I'm going parses
in the thinned image.
This function's a lot quicker than the last
one. Here's the result, so I will put that
on figure one and display the triple points
and little hard to see, there are only single
pixels are set here and if I can zoom in there's
one of the triple points.